I am old but I remember long ago when we
Norseman ruled the sea as our northern
kingdom expands the secret of our
success lay in how we built our fearsome
long ships imagine a young boy named
Harold who yearns to see the world his
father is a ship builder
he shares the secret to finding the
right trees he looks for a tall straight
trunk for the keel and clanking then he
finds the ship's frame hidden inside the
curved link the keel is Hulme from the
center of a trunk and laid down first
other logs are split for the long sleek
on planking is attached to the keel and
the inner framework is added last after
many months it's finished
a swift light and flexible moisture
piece as far out grows so does his
reputation for building good ship we use
the ships for exploration create warfare
and even burials for horror it's the
beginning of a long journey and his
first voyage is a raid on the Irish
coast
the Raiders returned home with good and
many slaves
years later oral takes his men around
the Iberian Peninsula to sail up the
Guadalquivir River
from there they attack the city of
Seville that's atmosphere and it is here
that morale grows his loss come with me
now
I've invited Horrell to my home for I
live in the realm of asgaard
[Music]
my name is Odin father of the Nordic
gods now I will hear horror story from
his own lips here in the halls of
Valhalla
[Music]
[Music]